Trascrizione: Nicoletta Pedrana
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Wow, che bello!
(Applausi)
Una sera di qualche anno fa,
mi trovavo nelle Filippine
assieme alla mia fornitrice di perle Kira.
Mi trovavo in questa spiaggia,
a guardare il rosa piano piano farsi blu.
E in quel momento, come dire -
è stato un momento
che io chiamo quasi mistico,
c’era questa bellezza,
che ad un certo punto
è diventata evidente per me.
Erano dei giorni particolari.
Io ero lì assieme a lei
a visitare uno degli unici posti al mondo
nei quali si pratica
la coltura sostenibile delle perle.
In quei giorni ho avuto modo di osservare
la cura estrema degli allevatori
verso l’ecosistema marino,
perché se qualcosa non va
non c’è modo di raccogliere
delle perle belle;
e visto che dietro ad ogni perla
c’è una famiglia della comunità,
non si può sbagliare.
Ho avuto modo di pensare alla natura
che sempre, malgrado gli sforzi dell’uomo,
alla fine sempre sfugge al suo governo,
perché malgrado l’impegno,
la ricerca, il monitoraggio
delle biologhe dell’allevamento,
quello che viene fuori da ogni raccolto
è sempre una sorpresa.
Ho avuto modo poi di rilevare
che, tuttavia, questa ingovernabilità
non è invincibilità,
perché l’allevamento,
per sostenere la barriera corallina,
aveva dovuto addirittura inventarsi
di far crescere dei coralli
nel proprio laboratorio
e poi di impiantarli.
Bene, quella sera, mentre mi sedevo
su questo piccolo lembo di terra
che mi teneva asciutta dall’acqua,
ho pensato l’esatta seguente frase:
"La bellezza è fragile".
Queste parole mi parevano
dare un senso a tutto,
sembravano far legittimare
una verità all’istante,
come se fosse un fatto di natura.
Era una frase molto semplice,
forse anche banale;
eppure per me rappresentava,
forse nel modo migliore possibile,
il mio lavoro sino ad allora:
cercare, cioè, materiali preziosi
che fossero belli,
di una bellezza completa,
cioè anche buoni.
Quando sono tornata a casa, però,
questa frase, questa sentenza,
benché semplice,
ha cominciato ad articolarsi
in domande sempre più sfingiche.
Vedete, quello che mi aveva colpita
non era l’evidenza
di una natura empia eppur frale,
che il bello naturale
potesse meravigliare con tanta forza
e allo stesso tempo, potesse risultare
così facilmente alterabile
da un’azione umana,
potesse essere così fragile.
Al contrario, a meravigliarmi
era stato il fatto
che quella bellezza che avevo sentito
fino quasi a pesarmi,
e che perciò mi sembrava incontestabile
nella sua fatticità,
quella cosa che chiamavo bellezza,
e che raccontavo agli altri come bellezza,
era tale solo perché in quel momento
ero stata disposta
a guardare, ad osservare,
ad essere aperta alla sua contemplazione.
Ecco, io, voi, noi, siamo fragili,
siamo umani, siamo transeunti.
Questa cosa che sentivo
di dover chiamare bellezza,
e che era indubbiamente potente,
perché ormai erano passati
giorni, settimane, mesi,
eppure quel momento continuava
ad interrogarmi e quasi a nutrirmi,
ecco, quella cosa chiamata bellezza
era comunque fragile,
perché dipende da noi.
Quindi, quale perdita
se quella sera non me ne fossi accorta,
se mi fossi limitata a godere
di una semplice circostanza piacevole,
come ce ne sono tante,
se non avessi riconosciuto la bellezza.
Ecco, non posso tardare
ancora a nominarla,
visto che parliamo di bellezza.
C’è una cosa che si aggira qui,
perché penso che in tanti
l’abbiate pensata,
e che è una frase della letteratura
e si aggira un po’ come,
mi piace pensare, lo spettro di Amleto
che poco dopo la mezzanotte
appare a Orazio.
E fa così:
"È vero, principe,
che una volta avete detto:
la bellezza salverà il mondo?
Signori, il principe afferma
che la bellezza salverà il mondo".
L’idiota, Dostoevskij.
"La bellezza salverà il mondo".
Che annuncio di salvezza, eh?
Ma quale bellezza salverà il mondo?
E come potrà salvare il mondo?
Nel romanzo, Dostoevskij purtroppo
non ci dà una risposta,
per lo meno una chiara;
e anzi la narrazione, spietata,
ci mostra che invece il mondo ostacola,
forse addirittura distrugge, la bellezza,
perché pervaso da prepotenza,
volgarità, ignoranza.
È una frase molto evocativa,
ma è un programma senza contenuti.
Ebbene, questa sera voglio provare a dire
che sì, forse, "la bellezza
salverà il mondo",
ma ad una condizione:
che essa stessa, la bellezza,
venga prima salvata dal mondo.
Ma ora devo fare un passo indietro,
perché ho praticamente detto già tutto,
ma senza dire nulla.
Ho fatto intendere che la bellezza
è una sorta di forza generatrice
e ho pure ipotizzato
che ha bisogno di noi per fare qualcosa.
Ma devo fermarmi perché, per procedere,
è prima necessario chiarire
su quale definizione
di bellezza stiamo discutendo.
Perché mi pare di notare
che noi parliamo
continuamente di bellezza.
Facciamo riferimento
continuamente alla bellezza
e continuamente utilizziamo
l’aggettivo "bello",
tanto che il più delle volte
è un’interiezione
che non vuol dire nulla
di interessante e di decisivo.
"Sì mi piace, questo è bello;
dai vieni che c’è bella gente;
è indubbiamente bello,
però a parte la bellezza? ".
Noi diciamo "bello" un po’ tutto quello
che ci appare moralmente accettabile,
in qualche modo affascinante;
ma anche quello
che riteniamo superficiale,
che nasconde il vero volto delle cose.
Questa vaghezza però, questa oscillazione,
accade per una ragione ben precisa,
e cioè che è davvero difficile
parlare di bellezza;
e per questo ci rifugiamo
nelle intuizioni personali,
nel relativismo.
Si suol dire, infatti,
"Non è bello ciò che è bello,
è bello ciò che piace"
e si suol sollecitare i più
a "guardare oltre l’estetica".
Pare un garbuglio.
Ebbene, cominciamo dall’estetica.
Che cos’è l’estetica?
Nel linguaggio comune,
"estetica" indica l’aspetto
e i caratteri esterni di qualcosa,
e lo fa nell’accezione negativa
di una semplice apparenza,
di qualcosa che deve essere superato
per giungere alla parte
degna di un presunto interesse.
In verità la parola deriva
dal greco "àisthesis",
che vuol dire "sensazione",
ma anche "percepire attraverso
la mediazione dei sensi".
Noi siamo sempre coinvolti
dalle sensazioni, immersi in esse.
Non abbiamo modo di distanziarcene
al fine di poterle rappresentare
come se fossero un oggetto esterno.
L’estetica, dunque, si occupa
di indagare e studiare
le qualità e le prestazioni
di questa nostra peculiare
sensibilità umana.
E dunque va ad esplorare ed indagare
il modo nel quale conosciamo:
dunque il linguaggio, l’immaginazione,
la creatività, l’inventare,
lo sperimentare,
anche scientifici,
soprattutto scientifici.
L’estetica si occupa del modo
nel quale incontriamo il mondo.
Non è qualcosa di secondario,
ma di primario.
È in questa prospettiva
che desidero proporvi la seguente
definizione di bellezza:
Suona così: "La bellezza
è il tesoro più grande".
Non sono mie parole, ovviamente:
è Goethe, è il Faust,
è l’opera che racconta dell’uomo
che vuole portare nel mondo
la bellezza e viverla.
Qui la parola chiave è "tesoro",
che non va inteso come cosa
importante in senso astratto;
al contrario, qui tesoro indica
quella cosa precisa e concreta,
quella che deve essere cercata
con fatica e con fiducia,
se necessario anche scavando,
come se fosse uno scrigno
pieno di tesori, gioielli,
interrato nel passato.
Ma c’è anche, nella parola "tesoro"
la connessione
con il mistero, con l’altro,
con l’infinito, con l’indefinito,
perché cercare è anche avventurarsi,
muoversi nel buio,
addentrarsi in posti altrimenti ignoti.
E il risultato, il premio
di questa impresa coraggiosa,
il tesoro,
non è mica una cosa garantita.
Si potrebbe anche non trovare nulla.
Se però l’avrai trovato, questo tesoro,
bisognerà anche fare lo sforzo
di portarlo indietro tutto intero,
perché sarà difficile, sul posto,
fare la cernita di quale parte
tenere e quale lasciare.
In altre parole sarà difficile,
tutto d’un tratto,
riuscire a capirne il significato.
Perché senza di esso
non potremmo comprenderne il valore,
e quindi capirne appieno
come metterlo al sicuro.
Ebbene, la bellezza, abbiamo detto,
è preziosa come un tesoro
e può salvare il mondo;
ma è anche fragile perché è legata
a noi, in qualche modo.
Dunque, per salvarci
dovrà prima essere salvata;
ma come facciamo a salvare la bellezza?
Come facciamo a salvare qualcosa
di cui è difficile addirittura parlare?
Vorrei provare a dire:
facendo accadere due cose.
Innanzitutto, imparando
a trovare la bellezza.
Per trovare la bellezza, altro non serve
che uno sguardo di apertura al mondo,
di disponibilità all’ascolto
e alla ricezione.
È una disposizione d’animo, infatti,
che è possibile a chiunque;
e che si acquisisce,
e soprattutto si mantiene,
confrontandoci con quello
che non ci è familiare:
è la fatica di formarsi,
di informarsi, di leggere,
di educarsi all’arte, alla poesia
e alla sensibilità filosofica.
È l’impegno costante
di dare attenzione e credito
agli stimoli che ci arrivano
dai nostri sensi, da tutti i nostri sensi.
Anche da quello più bistrattato di tutti,
che è l’olfatto.
È, provo a dirlo ancora meglio,
la fatica di prendere le distanze,
almeno la sera quando siamo a casa,
dall’educazione scientifica,
tecnica e funzionale
che la nostra epoca ci chiede e ci impone;
e di nutrirci, al contrario,
di educazione estetica
e degli stimoli
che ci arrivano dall’esterno.
Per trovare la bellezza,
bisogna essere aperti
a tutte le possibilità,
anche a costo di non capire
e di sentirsi disorientati,
e di perdersi momentaneamente.
Ora che siamo pronti,
disposti a trovare la bellezza,
come facciamo a cercarla?
Ecco, accostandoci al mondo,
tenendo in una mano
tutto quello che abbiamo -
la nostra cultura
e la nostra sensibilità umana -
e nell’altra niente,
perché dobbiamo essere pronti
a raccogliere ed accogliere
qualsiasi cosa,
anche quello che sembra
invisibile e senza senso.
A questo punto, quello che troviamo
possiamo sfacciatamente
chiamarlo bellezza,
ha la forma dell’enigma, dello stupore,
di qualcosa che ci dà da pensare.
Ebbene, abbiamo trovato la bellezza,
abbiamo trovato il tesoro,
ma non siamo ancora alla fine
del nostro percorso.
Ricordate?
Trovato il tesoro, bisogna riuscire
a portarlo indietro tutto intero
per poterne capire
il valore e il significato,
e tenerlo al sicuro.
Quindi dobbiamo sforzarci
di dare una forma, e un senso,
a questa cosa multiforme,
forse anche informe,
che chiamiamo bellezza
e che ci viene incontro
e che ci interroga.
Perché soltanto dandole
un tentativo di forma,
soltanto in quel modo
potremo renderla comunicabile
e così passarla agli altri.
Ecco la seconda cosa da fare
per salvare la bellezza: condividerla.
Anche questo, come lo sforzo
di trovare la bellezza,
è qualcosa che è possibile a chiunque.
Certo, chi ha il talento di produrre
qualcosa di totalmente unico e originale,
vale a dire il genio,
riuscirà a farlo in maniera potentissima:
questi sono gli artisti
e le persone che più ci ispirano.
Ma questo non vuol dire che noi altri
non possiamo fare nulla.
Magari potremo non essere geniali,
ma possiamo ancora essere creativi,
perché tale è per natura Homo Sapiens.
Possiamo sforzarci di spiegare,
di cercare di elaborare
con i mezzi che abbiamo,
qualsiasi essi siano.
Se pensiamo di aver trovato della bellezza
in un libro o in un film,
invece di limitarci a suggerirlo
velocemente ai nostri amici,
sforziamoci di parlarne,
di indagare, con noi e con loro,
questa cosa che abbiamo incontrato
e che sentiamo di chiamare bellezza.
Perché solo con questo sforzo
non solo la renderemo comunicabile,
ma così facendo la passeremo agli altri
e le daremo un luogo,
un posto in cui stare al sicuro.
Un po’ come uno scrigno
dove mettere un tesoro.
Questo è l’atto eroico
di cercare la bellezza,
trovarla e riportarla nel mondo,
innescandone la potenza salvifica
attraverso uno sforzo collettivo
di rielaborazione e di condivisione.
"L’umanità - scrive Dostoevskij
in un'altra opera -
può vivere senza la scienza,
può vivere senza il pane,
ma soltanto senza la bellezza
non potrebbe più vivere,
perché non ci sarebbe più nulla
da fare al mondo.
Tutto il segreto è qui,
tutta la storia è qui".
Un attimo.
Prima ho invocato Orazio.
Ricordate qual è l’ultima cosa
che Amleto chiede al suo amico,
prima di morire?
Dice: "Tu vivi.
Ricorda me, e la mia causa,
a chi è dubbioso".
Amleto chiede ad Orazio di raccontare.
(Applausi)